those of you who have followed my work
know that i am often described as both
sophisticated and artsy
that's how i describe myself anyway
during my morning affirmations probably
no one else
would think of me like that but today
i'm going to try to embrace
uh or conjure up an artsy and
sophisticated side
by reviewing some modern art many people
when they look at modern art they say
things like
this is garbage uh this is trash it's
nonsensical this is ugly this is boring
this is
dull why am i looking at this i'm hungry
at least that's what i said the one time
in my life when i was forced to go to an
art museum
but those are back in my primitive
barbaric you know uncultured days i have
grown i've matured since then
and now perhaps i'll be able to fully
appreciate this meaningless
[ __ ] so we'll find out where to go
through some uh these are some
you know i guess paintings by prominent
or semi-prominent modern artist the
first
one is a painting called the girl who
had everything by
cecily brown and uh there it is there
the girl who had everything she had
everything including
epilepsy from the look of it because
this this to me just looks like
the a guy was mixing paint at home depot
and stroked out
and spilled it all over the floor
nothing discernible happening here
except for well i do see okay so there
is there is some kind of um
like situation there's a there's a
buttocks-like structure in the lower end
of the painting
hello so someone spilled the paint and
then somebody else came along and said
hey
check it out and they made a butt bear
no
it's art and that's the story of this
painting and i'm sure it sold for
600 billion dollars next we have
keith herring uh is the artist and he
this is a painting called untitled
and it is i mean it's literally
something that my eight-year-old
daughter could draw
this this isn't even good for an
eight-year-old okay
this isn't this isn't one that you put
on a fridge it's not fridge worthy
worthy put it on the refrigerator i want
to keep this upstairs in my desk
this is one where you go oh oh thank you
good drawing and as soon as they leave
the room you throw it in the trash
[Music]
and then later they fight it in the
trash and they go daddy what's why is
this in the trash and you say
where was it there's a trash what was it
doing there i don't know how it got
there
uh and then you throw it away again when
they leave the room this is garbage
um okay next one is uh titled
un this is also untitled by jean vasquez
uh these people they can't even bother
come up with titles for their for their
paintings
and they can't be bothered to spend more
than 12 minutes on their painting
or even to make a title and the thing is
this monstrosity right here i actually
remember this one
this sold for a hundred million dollars
huh
what you're looking at that's no joke
the best thing i could say about this is
that it looks like something that a
moody seventh grader
might have painted in 1998 because he
was mad
that he got kicked out of hot topic for
stealing nail polish
okay next one is called the tree by
ibrahim l
salahi and the first thing that jumps
out at you when you look at this
you look at the tree is that there's no
tree in sight there's not anything it's
just random shapes and colors
this is maybe the best thing i could say
of just being generous if if
is that maybe i would say
this looks a little bit like maybe
high-end wrapping paper this is the kind
of wrapping paper
that i might use and my wife will go oh
this is pretty neat wrapping paper and
then she'll end up being more impressed
by the wrapping paper than the thing
inside
because the thing inside is like a
hand-me-down form and grill let's keep
moving quickly to lost horizons by
keenan derby
the color scheme the textures
all of that to me it brings to mind
maybe the carpet in a pediatrician's
waiting room
or alternatively this this might be the
last thing you see if you're trapped
inside a crayola factory and it explodes
and that's being generous i'm being as
generous as i can with all this stuff
there are people who go to museums and
like will stare at that
and make comments about about it oh
yeah look it's a sailboat you saw it too
damn it
uh similar for this one is portal to
lhasa by
natalia roble
this one actually i i wouldn't even be
impressed with this if my eight-year-old
made it
i i i'm not even kidding if my
eight-year-old presented that to me i
would
i would scold them for for
giving me such a poorly thought out
piece of art
uh there's just nothing happening there
at all in a way it
sort of like says
so much by
saying so little the colors don't work
together it is real
it's just random colors there's no
if i were to if i were to have my let's
just say my one year old
do a painting and i would have put it up
next to that you wouldn't be able to
tell
which one was done by the the the highly
prized artist and which one was done by
my eight-year-old um same goes for this
this is willem de kooning's
[Music]
interchange
and this sold for 300 million dollars
300 million is that that's got to be a
typo
three my god in heaven give okay give me
half of that i'll take
half of that i'll take a poultry let's
just call it 150 million
and i will gladly scribble with colored
pencils over a canvas with my eyes
closed i would
happily do it for you know what i would
this is how generous i am
i'll do it for 50 million but i'm losing
on the deal if that's what you want
give me 50 million and i'll do that
and honestly i think that's what i hate
about modern art most of all is that uh
is it is jealousy i'll admit that
because i am also a bad artist just like
uh this guy what's his name again
willem de kooning i'm a terrible artist
just like william de kooning
he makes 300 million i get nothing i'm
poor and destitute
okay finally uh well we can't go much
further i but
here's here's one other thing that i
think is worth looking at
this is woman three by willem de kooning
oh same guy okay so we've got a second
one by the same guy
[Music]
and uh this monstrosity sold for 160
million dollars
oh hell no really a bargain compared to
the other one
so the other ones it's by the same guy
the other one sold for 300 million this
is 160 million which is not like that's
half off
and this one at least looks like
something this is this
sort of vaguely resembles a thing that
you might
recognize the more nonsensical it is
the more impressed people are by it that
i love i absolutely love
that's just the air conditioner but this
one
if your child made this first of all you
would steer them away from art classes
because you realize this is clearly not
a skill that they have it's not worth
trying to foster
and second you probably call therapists
because this is the kind of thing
that a patient that a mental asylum
would scribble on the floor of the
bathroom in their own bodily fluid
that's what that's what that is
and i don't mean that as a compliment
and it all goes to show
beauty is not in the eye of the beholder
maybe we could put that
to rest once and for all if you think
that any of this is beautiful you're
simply
you're that's not just an opinion you're
wrong you're objectively wrong
all that to say um i didn't really like
any of it
well if you enjoyed that content for
whatever reason make sure to hit
like and subscribe and i'm not going to
yell at you this time i'm just
demanding that you do it right now